David Boder: [In English] September 19, 1946 in a large refugee center in the Funkkasernen we are interviewing Mr. Julius Klüver, a leader of the Mennonite Group, which moved gradually from [Name der Stadt unverständlich] Russia up to the American Zone in Germany.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie uns wieder, Herr Klüver, wie heißen Sie, wie alt sind Sie, wo sind Sie geboren?
Julius Klüver: Ich heiße Julius Klüver, bin 43 Jahre alt. Bin geboren in [unverständlich] Ekaterinslav Dneprovsk in der Ukraine auf dem Gut meines Vaters [Name des Gutes unverständlich ].
David Boder: Also gut, Herr Klüver, wo waren Sie und was hat Ihnen passiert wenn der Krieg angefangen hat?
Julius Klüver: Als der Krieg anfing war ich in der Ukraine in der Stadt [unverständlich]. Ich arbeitete in einer Fabrik als Buchhalter.
David Boder: Also was hat Ihnen passiert als der Krieg angefangen hat?
Julius Klüver: Als der Krieg anfing arbeitete ich weiter in der Fabrik bis die Deutschen kamen. Es war das Bestreben der Mennoniten, sowie mein Bestreben so schnell wie möglich nach dem Westen zu gehen, und am besten zu unseren Mennoniten nach Kanada, den USA oder Paraguay zu gehen. Das war unser altes Ziel—noch von 1920—und dem Ziel wollten wir nachgehen.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir mal, wie viele Mennoniten waren in Ihrer Gemeinde?
Julius Klüver: Im Jahre 1930 waren es ungefähr achtzig tausend [80.000] Mennoniten.
David Boder: Wo haben die alle gelebt?
Julius Klüver: Gelebt haben die Meisten in Süd-Russland.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, waren die meisten Mennoniten Deutsche?
Julius Klüver: Die Mennoniten sind Holländer, holländischer Abstammung. Sie kamen von Holland nach Süd Russland auf den Ruf der Kaiserin Katharina, der Zweiten, und später, sowie mein Vater, der kam auch später, kamen, hm, kamen nach Russland und die sind da, um die Ukraine zu kolonisieren. Sie, hm, sie gingen von Holland und von der Süd—von der Westküste zu der Nordküste und gingen sie weg wegen ihrem Religionsbekenntnis und wegen der Wehrbekenntnis. In Russland wurde uns versprochen, dass wir die Wehrbekenntnis können halten
David Boder: Und was soll das heißen?
Julius Klüver: . . . also nicht als Soldaten eingezogen werden gegen unser Religionsbekenntnis.
David Boder: Und nun und das haben die Russen gehalten?
Julius Klüver: Das haben die Russen gehalten bis 1920.
David Boder: Hat der Zar niemals die Mennoniten einberufen?
Julius Klüver: In der Zaren Zeit brauchten wir das Gewehr nicht zu nehmen, wir mussten Arbeitsdienst für die Försterei leiten.
David Boder: Und dann—wann wurden die Mennoniten zum ersten Mal einberufen?
Julius Klüver: Als die, die Sowjet Republik—zur Zeit der Gründung der Sowjet Republik.
David Boder: Dann fingen sie an die Mennoniten einzuberufen? Was haben die Mennoniten dann getan?
Julius Klüver: Die Mennoniten haben sich abgesagt und wurden dafür—kamen dafür vors Gericht. So wurde auch ich 1923 vor das Gericht gerufen und es dauerte sehr lange bis ich wegen meiner religiösen Bekenntnis vom Wehrdienst freigesprochen wurde. Und 1923...
David Boder: Und wie wurden Sie frei?
Julius Klüver: Man konnte freigesprochen werden nur auf weil das Gericht—das sowjetische Gericht uns davon freisprach.
David Boder: Hat das Sowjet Gericht jeden Einzelnen vor Gericht gezogen?
Julius Klüver: Es sind viele von unseren jungen Männern in der Zeit vors Gericht gegangen, viele wurden vors Gericht gegeben. Viele sind freigesprochen worden, viele nicht.
David Boder: Und was hat man mit denen getan, die nicht freigesprochen wurden?
Julius Klüver: Man hat Einige einberufen, aber die meisten mussten Arbeitsdienst in Sibirien leisten.
David Boder: Nun, also, was hat passiert, wie die Deutschen nach Russland kamen?
Julius Klüver: Als jetzt die Deutschen nach Russland kamen, so ist ein Teil von Mennoniten sofort nach dem Westen gegangen.
David Boder: Das heißt—den Deutschen begegnet?
Julius Klüver: Nein, also die haben sich zurück nach dem Westen gezogen. Uns wäre es einerlei gewesen, wer gekommen wäre, wäre es ein französische Armee gewesen oder eine holländische Armee oder eine türkische Armee gewesen—wir wollten nur weg aus dem Osten.
David Boder: Warum?
Julius Klüver: Weil unsere Eltern, unsere Geschwister, unsere Männer fast alle waren im Exil in Sibirien. Uns wurde all das Hab und Gut abgenommen.
David Boder: Und wann ist das passiert?
Julius Klüver: Das ist passiert vom Jahre 1920 bis 1935. So, zum Beispiel, bei mir; mein Vater war reich und hatte ein Gut. Mein Vater wurde 1920 erschossen, weil er ein reicher Mann war. Ich war ein junger Mann von 17 Jahren und ich habe mich jahrelang versteckt gehalten, um nicht erschossen zu werden. Also mein Ziel war nur weg zu unseren Brüdern nach Kanada. In Kanada habe ich drei [3] Schwestern. Keine Geschwister hab ich mehr hier. Meine Frau hat vier [4] Schwestern in Kanada, wir wollten nur zurück zu unseren Mennoniten. So, zum Beispiel, von meinen zehn [10] Onkeln, die ich da hatte, sind neun [9] sind neun [9] Onkel weg. Fünf [5] sind in Sibirien gestorben, vier [4] sind im Gefängnis gestorben und verhaftet wurden sie nur deshalb, weil sie reiche Leute waren.
David Boder: Nun, also, wie—wann fingen Sie an nach dem Westen zu gehen? Wann sind die Deutschen—haben Sie in Saratov damals gelebt, wie die Deutschen kamen?
Julius Klüver: Nein.
David Boder: Ja?
Julius Klüver: Ich, ich lebte in Zaporoje. Als die Deutschen im Winter 41 herein kamen, im Jahre 42 ging ein Teil von uns schon nach Polen. Ich ging im Anfang des Jahres 43 nach Polen.
David Boder: Haben die Deutschen das erlaubt?
Julius Klüver: Ja, die haben es erlaubt. Wir konnten, wir konnten nach...nach dem Westen gehen. Ich ging nach Polen und war in Polen beinah zwei [2] Jahre. Als aber die Front näher kam nach Polen, ging ich von Polen weiter nach Deutschland. Da kam ich bis Chemnitz. In Chemnitz war ich nur 2 Wochen, dann kam der große Fliegerangriff. Ich wurde ausgebombt und ich entfloh mit meiner Familie weiter nach dem Westen. So kam ich nach München.
David Boder: Wann kamen Sie nach München?
Julius Klüver: Nach München kam ich im...im Januar 1945.
David Boder: Haben die Deutschen von den Mennoniten einen Arbeitsdienst verlangt?
Julius Klüver: Einige...einige von Mennoniten mussten arbeiten. Einige wurden sogar einberufen oder sollten einberufen werden. Und...und...aber Wenige sind gegangen. Die Meisten waren auf ihren religiösen Stand wegen der Wehrlosigkeit und haben gearbeitet—verschiedene Arbeiten und haben sich dem Wehrdienst entzogen.
David Boder: Nun und wo...wie viele Mennoniten sind jetzt hier in diesem Lager zu diesem Punkt?
Julius Klüver: In diesem Lager sind wir fünfhundert zweiundfünzig [552] Mennoniten, wo die Meisten nach Paraguay gehen wollen. Und von denen...und...und Einige wollen nach Kanada gehen zu den Verwandten, von denen die schon Affidavit haben.
David Boder: Dann haben die Kanadier den Mennoniten erlaubt nicht in den Wehrdienst einzutreten?
Julius Klüver: Ja, die Kanadier selbst– so viel wie mir bekannt ist—haben in diesem Krieg auch meistenteils nur Arbeitsdienst geleistet. Nur Einige sind freiwillig in den Wehrmachtsdienst gegangen.
David Boder: Was meinen Sie—die Kanadier im Allgemeinen oder die kanadischen Mennoniten?
Julius Klüver: Die Kanadischen Mennoniten.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, wie haben sich diese 500 Mennoniten versammelt? Mit wie Vielen sind Sie weg gegangen?
Julius Klüver: Ich bin mit meiner Familie weg gegangen.
David Boder: Wie viel Leute waren das?
Julius Klüver: Vier Personen. Hier haben wir uns gesammelt aus der ganzen amerikanischen Zone. Einzeln, fast alles Frauen und Kinder.
David Boder: Wo sind die Männer?
Julius Klüver: Die Männer, die Meisten sind in Sibirien. Die wurden verhaftet im Jahre 36 und 37 in Russland, noch vor dem Kriege.
David Boder: Und diesen Männer wurde erlaubt in Sibirien Mennoniten zu sein?
Julius Klüver: Die sind in Haft, im Lager, als, hm, in Arbeit stehend. Wir haben keine Nachricht von Ihnen und die Frauen wissen auch nicht, ob sie noch am Leben sind oder nicht.
David Boder: Also von den 500 Personen, die hier versammelt sind, wie viele sind da erwachsene Männer?
Julius Klüver: Es sind ungefähr ein Drittel Männer.
David Boder: Und die Anderen sind Frauen und Kinder?
Julius Klüver: Frauen und Kinder. Wir haben ungefähr 250 Kinder hier.
David Boder: Und denken Sie, dass, dass die Kanadier Sie rein lassen werden?
Julius Klüver: Ja, das denke ich sicher. Also nach Paraguay haben wir schon die Erlaubnis und in kurzer Zeit soll der erste Transport mit 430 Mennoniten nach Paraguay gehen, wo auch ganze mennonitische Kolonien sind in, in Paraguay. Die gehen zu ihren Verwandten nach Paraguay und zu ihren Bekannten in diesen mennonitischen Kolonien.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, wieso kommt es, wie viele Generationen von Ihrer Familie haben in Russland gelebt?
Julius Klüver: Mein Grossvater kam nach Russland als Kleiner, als Kind.
David Boder: Also das war ungefähr wie viele Jahre zurück?
Julius Klüver: Das war ungefähr achtzig [80] oder neunzig [90] Jahre zurück, neunzig [90] Jahre zurück.
David Boder: Und sagen Sie mir, wieso kommt es, dass die Mennoniten in Russland die deutsche Sprache behalten haben?
Julius Klüver: Weil wir hatten, wir sprechen untereinander immer noch holländisch, das friesische Platt. Wir haben nur die Gesangbücher, unsere, unsere Bibel und Schulbücher haben wir in deutscher Sprache. Anfänglich waren wir in holländischer Sprache, aber weil in Süd-Russland viele deutsche Kolonien waren unter den Mennonitischen, und der deutsche Markt mit Büchern, die mehr aus dem Fach waren, hat unsere Schule und die Religion den Jungs die Bücher in deutscher Sprache gegeben. Wir aber sprechen zu Hause—auch jetzt hier—alle unter uns nur die holländische Sprache.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, Herr Klüver, in welcher Hinsicht unterscheiden sich die Mennonitischen Religion von den anderen Protestantischen Religionen mit Ausnahme der [unverständlich] Gewehr tragen?
Julius Klüver: Erstens die Hauptsache ist, bei uns ist nicht Kleintaufe sondern Großtaufe. Das ist die, die erste Hauptlinie.
David Boder: Was ist die Großtaufe?
Julius Klüver: Also bei uns werden sie getauft, wenn siebzehn [17], achtzehn [18], neunzehn [19] Jahre alt. Nicht als klein, sondern erst wenn man das Alter zwischen siebzehn [17] und neunzehn [19] Jahre erreicht.
David Boder: Zweitens?
Julius Klüver: Zweitens ist die Wehrlosigkeit. Drittens schwören wir nicht.
David Boder: Sie schwören nicht?
Julius Klüver: Nein. Wir sagen ja, ja oder nein, nein, aber ein Gelübde oder einen Schwur legen wir nicht an.
David Boder: Nicht einmal zu ihren, hm, Lande, zu Ihrem Vaterland?
Julius Klüver: Auch nicht.
David Boder: Aber was sind die Anderen...aber anders sie sind im allgemeinen Protestant?
Julius Klüver: Protestant, ja protestantisch.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, wo waren Sie dann in der letzten Zeit des Krieges, das letzte Jahr des Krieges, wenn Deutschland schon den Krieg allmählich verloren hat?
Julius Klüver: Ich war von 43, von anfangs 43 bis Ende 45 in Polen. Ich lebte in Leibenstadt, ich arbeite als Buchhalter in einem Betrieb
David Boder: In Polen?
Julius Klüver: In Polen.
David Boder: Und wann sind Sie in die amerikanische Zone gegangen?
Julius Klüver: Zur amerikanischen Zone kam ich im Januar 1945.
David Boder: Und bevor waren sie in Polen?
Julius Klüver: In Polen.
David Boder: Nun da kamen doch...wo waren Sie als die Russen nach Polen kamen?
Julius Klüver: Als die Front näher nach Polen kam, ging ich zurück zu einigen guten Bekannten und westlich nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Haben die Deutschen das erlaubt?
Julius Klüver: Ja, sie haben das erlaubt.
David Boder: Nun waren Sie in irgendwelchen Gegenden, die schwer gebombt worden sind?
Julius Klüver: Ich war...von Polen kam ich nach Chemnitz. Da war ich zwei [2] Wochen und wollte mir da Arbeit suchen. Und ich hatte mir auch ein Zimmer gemietet da, aber das Haus wurde in zwei [2] Wochen ganz zerbombt und ich wollte mit nur einem Koffer meiner Familie das Leben retten und bin zu Fuß nach der Stadt Weier und von Weier nach München. In München lebte mein Vetter und ich hab mich dem angeschlossen.
David Boder: Lebte er immer in München oder war er auch ein Flüchtling?
Julius Klüver: Er war auch ein Flüchtling, er kam von Russland 1942.
David Boder: Und dann, hm, haben Sie sich hier allmählich versammelt und sind jetzt fertig weiter zu reisen?
Julius Klüver: Wir waren...als wir nach München kamen, wurde ich in der Stadt nicht untergebracht. Ich ging—ich musste gehen zu den Bauern [unverständlich]. Die Familie war auch mit mir beim Bauern. [unverständlich - ganz besonders starkes Rauschen im Hintergrund des Tonbandes]. Ich habe da über ein Jahr als Knecht beim Bauern gearbeitet.
David Boder: Und wo war ihre Familie?
Julius Klüver: Die Familie war auch mit mir beim Bauern.
David Boder: Sie haben eine Frau und zwei [2] Kinder?
Julius Klüver: Eine Frau und zwei [2] Töchter, die haben alle gearbeitet beim Bauern.
David Boder: Beim Bauern?
Julius Klüver: Ja, ohne Bezahlung, wir lebten mit unserer Lebensmittelkarte und bekamen zusätzlich etwas Milch von ihm.
David Boder: Was heißt gelebt mit Ihrer Lebensmittelkarte? Hat der Bauer sie nicht gefüttert?
Julius Klüver: Nein, also es war so. Wir bekamen unsere Lebensmittelkarten und dazu mussten arbeiten. Zusätzlich haben wir etwas Milch von ihm bekommen.
David Boder: Und das andere Essen haben Sie bezahlen müssen?
Julius Klüver: Das habe ich bezahlt.
David Boder: Wo von haben Sie das bezahlt?
Julius Klüver: Ich hatte noch Geld von meinem früheren Verdienst. Es war nicht—da brauchte man nicht viel Geld zu haben, um die Lebensmittel aufzukaufen, die man jetzt bekam auf die Karte.
David Boder: Sie sagen, Sie hatten noch etwas mit, was für ein Geld war das?
Julius Klüver: Das waren Deutsche Mark, Reichsmark.
David Boder: Wann haben Sie die umgetauscht von Rubel?
Julius Klüver: Russische Rubel, das war nicht gespart in Russischen Rubel. Das war das, was ich in Polen verdient habe. Das bekamen wir schon bezahlt in Deutschen Reichsmark. Also von Russischen Rubeln hatte ich kein Geld, also keine Ersparnis.
David Boder: Also wollen wir das klar machen. Sie und Ihre Familie haben bei einem Bauern gearbeitet. Nicht wahr?
Julius Klüver: Ja.
David Boder: Und der hat Ihnen das Essen nicht frei gegeben?
Julius Klüver: Das war wegen dem Gesetz. Wer Lebensmittelkarten hat, darf nicht beim Bauern essen, wenn er sein eigenes Aus...Aushalt hat.
David Boder: Ja, wozu haben Sie die Lebensmittelkarten genommen?
Julius Klüver: Das war so, das war so—alle Flüchtlinge haben gelebt und haben Karten bekommen. Weil ich meine Familie mit mir hatte. Wenn ich ledig wäre, hätt ich können...die Lebensmittelkarte nicht bekommen und bei ihm essen, beim Bauern. Aber weil ich Familie hatte, deshalb hab ich mit der Familie...
David Boder: Aha.
Julius Klüver: Die Frau hat selber gekocht.
David Boder: Aha. Und Sie bezahlten ihr Essen mit den Karten, Sie haben ihm die Karten, die Lebensmittelkarten gegeben und er gab Ihnen ab und zu etwas Milch? Und er hat Ihnen nichts gezahlt?
Julius Klüver: Nein, Geld hat er mir nicht gezahlt. Er hat gesagt wir arbeiten für die Wohnung und für die, für die paar Sachen, die er mir gegeben hat. Ich hatte einen Tisch und ein paar Stühle und dafür musste ich arbeiten.
David Boder: Was heißt er hat sie gegeben?
Julius Klüver: Er hat sie rein gestellt in mein Zimmer.
David Boder: Oh, er hat Sie Ihnen gegeben!
Julius Klüver: Ja.
David Boder: Nun war dieser Bauer ein Nazi?
Julius Klüver: Er war bis 1936 Nazi. Dann ist er aus der Partei rausgegangen, weil er Angst hatte und würde sein Gut verlieren. Er war ein reicher Bauer, ein [unverständlich] Bauer und deshalb hat er nicht mit den Nazis gestimmt. Er meinte, dass mit der Zeit es wird solche Gesellschaften geben, die darauf aus sind Genossenschaften daraus...
David Boder: Wie in Russland die landwirtschaftlichen Genossenschaften?
Julius Klüver: Ja, so was auf diese Art, deshalb war...wurde er mit der Zeit gegen die Nazis gestimmt. Anfänglich war er mit ihnen und war ein Parteimitglied bis 1936.
David Boder: Und Sie glauben, dass solch ein Bauer nicht durch Bekannte oder Verwandte gewusst hat was in den Konzentrationslagern vorgeht?
Julius Klüver: Ich denk, er kann es nicht gewusst haben. Er hat auch wenig Interesse daran. Und Gemeinschaft hatte er auch keine. Hier in Bayern hatten die Bauern sehr kleine Gemeinschaften untereinander.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, Sie haben doch die Deutschen beobachten können, was hat der Bauer über den Krieg gedacht?
Julius Klüver: Viele von ihnen haben geglaubt, dass Deutschland gewinnen wird. Aber Viele haben auch prophezeit, dass Deutschland den Krieg nie gewinnen wird, denn die Übermacht war zu gross.
David Boder: Und wo waren Sie an dem Tage als Deutschland sich ergeben hat?
Julius Klüver: Da war ich in diesem Dorf beim Bauern.
David Boder: Nun was haben die Leute dann gesagt?
Julius Klüver: Sehr viele von den Deutschen haben sich sehr gefreut, dass der Krieg zu Ende ist und damit ihre Söhne nach Hause kommen. Und dann haben sich dann sind die Bauern wieder ihrer Arbeit gewidmet. Sie haben sich gedacht: ‚Wir werden es jetzt schlecht haben anfänglich—aber mit der Zeit werden wir uns doch wieder vollständig erholen.“ Sie haben Hoffnung gehabt für eine bessere Zukunft.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, haben die Bauern während des Krieges gut gegessen?
Julius Klüver: Die Meisten ja. Die haben es verstanden nicht alles abzuliefern und da hatten sie für sich und haben wohl [unverständlich—starkes Rauschen im Tonband], die Meisten.
David Boder: Und nun als Beobachter—was denken Sie von der deutschen Lage jetzt?
Julius Klüver: Ja, wie soll ich Ihnen dies erklären? Ich habe so wenig Interesse an der Lage jetzt hier, mein Interesse und meine Gedanken sind nur drüben. So schnell wie möglich von hier weg, dass ich endlich eine Heimat habe. Seit 1920 habe ich keine Ruhe...keine ruhige Nacht gehabt und eigentlich möchte ich einmal—eine Nacht - in Ruhe schlafen. Und auch eine kleine, kleine Heimat zu haben. Hier denken viele Deutsche es wird ihnen bald wieder besser gehen. Von Vielen habe ich das gehört, wie ich im Dorf noch war. Das sie immerhin hoffen drei [3] oder vier [4] Jahre werden sie es schwer haben, aber dann werden sie doch ein besseres Leben haben, ein freieres Leben haben als zur Zeit der Nazi gehabt haben.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, was war das Verhältnis des Bauern, mit dem Sie gelebt haben, was war deren Verhältnis zu den Juden?
Julius Klüver: Das Verhalten zu den Juden war schlecht. Das habe ich gespürt bei den Bauern auch. Das jüdische Volk wurde nicht gemocht.
David Boder: Und wie stand es zwischen den Mennoniten in Russland?
Julius Klüver: Die Mennoniten haben keine Nation verachtet. Im Gegenteil—die Mennoniten haben sich auch für so eine religiös verfolgte Nation, wie die Juden, gefühlt. Wir haben uns sehr oft mit den Juden verglichen. Nur, dass wir ein kleines, armes Völkchen sind und die Juden sind sehr reich und in der Mehrzahl mehr und sie haben stärkere Organisationen. Wir sind zu wenig und zu schwach. Aber die Verfolgung, die religiöse Verfolgungen der letzten vier hundert [400] Jahre war so wie bei den Juden. Wir haben keine Heimat, wir haben kein Land, dass wir unseres nennen können. Wir waren in Holland, wir waren bei Danzig im polnischen Korridor, wir waren in Süd-Russland und nirgendwo finden wir eine Heimat.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, kann man eine Heimat haben, wenn man diese Heimat nicht mit Gewehr verteidigen will?
Julius Klüver: Nach unserer Ansicht—ja. Nach unserem Glauben und religiösen Bekenntnis kann man eine Heimat haben, auch wenn man sie nicht mit dem Gewehr verteidigen kann.
David Boder: In allen anderen Fällen—erkennen die Mennoniten den Staat an? Das heißt, zahlen Sie Steuern?
Julius Klüver: Ja, ja, in allen Fällen—die Mennoniten—wir bezahlen Steuern...
David Boder: Erkennen Sie den Staat an?
Julius Klüver: Wir erkennen den Staat an.
David Boder: Haben Sie je gehört von der Sekte in Amerika—die Jehovas Zeugnisse?
Julius Klüver: Nein.
David Boder: Das ist eine andere Sekte, wie, zum Beispiel die Dukhobors, die wollen keine Steuern zahlen.
Julius Klüver: Nein, habe ich noch nie gehört.
David Boder: So, die Mennoniten zahlen ihre Steuern?
Julius Klüver: Sehr gern. Bitte ich weiß von früher und auch jetzt—wir sind nicht geizig. Wir zahlen, wir wollen arbeiten, wir wollen auch unsere Religion haben und wir wollen unsere Pflichten gegen den Staat erfüllen.
David Boder: Sie sagten, Sie arbeiten als Buchhalter, gibt es viele Mennoniten, die nicht auf dem Lande arbeiten?
Julius Klüver: Sehr wenig. Die Meisten sind alle Bauern.
David Boder: Gibt es welche Mennoniten in Mexiko?
Julius Klüver: Ja, es gibt Mennoniten in Mexiko.
David Boder: Wo leben diese?
Julius Klüver: Das kann ich Ihnen nicht genau sagen, ich weiß nur, dass es in Mexiko auch Mennoniten gibt.
David Boder: Waren diese von Kanada übersiedelt oder sie direkt von Russland gekommen?
Julius Klüver: Das kann ich Ihnen genau nicht sagen.
David Boder: Und wieso sind sie nach Paraguay gekommen?
Julius Klüver: Die, die haben schon ab April [unverständlich] ein Bestimmung von der Paraguay Regierung, dass alle Mennoniten—ohne jegliche Bedingung—frei nach diesem Land kommen können - ohne Gesundheitskontrolle des Gesundheitszustandes können alle nach Paraguay kommen. Das sind unsere Mennoniten, die haben in dem großen Chaco Gebiet, wo keiner richtig konnte durchkommen, da haben unsere Mennoniten Kolonien gebaut und unsere Kolonien blühen dort.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal—in ihrer Gruppe sind da mehr Frauen, wie Männer?
Julius Klüver: Viel mehr Frauen wie Männer.
David Boder: Also was wird aus diesen Frauen werden? Viele von ihnen werden nicht wissen, ob sie Witwen sind oder nicht. Und dann darf sich eine Mennonitin mit einem Nicht-Mennoniten verheiraten?
Julius Klüver: Nein. Sie dürfen—nach unseren Gesetzen—nur unsere Mennoniten heiraten.
David Boder: Nun wird es nicht eine schwierige Situation bringen?
Julius Klüver: Bis jetzt nicht. [Pause] Nein, ich meine nicht.
David Boder: Ich meine bloß vom Standpunkt, von unserem, dass ist doch eine schwere Situation sein wird, Frauen zu haben, die sich keine Männer finden können
Julius Klüver: Ja, das wird vielleicht schwer sein, aber wir haben bis, bisher in unseren Kolonien, haben wir bisher sehr wenige gemischte Ehen gehabt. Jetzt—in letzter Zeit ist es mehr geworden, weil von unseren Männern viele weg sind. Deswegen haben auch Mennonitische Frauen geheiratet mit Anderen als Mennoniten.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, Herr Klüver, tuen die Mennoniten Leute von anderen Religionen bekehren?
Julius Klüver: Nein, nein, das ist nur von unserer Gemeinde.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel sagen wir, wenn jemand Mennonite werden will, würden sie ihn aufnehmen?
Julius Klüver: Nein, er muss als Mennonite geboren werden. Das ist kein...nicht nur Religion...wir sehen uns als Volk.
David Boder: Also zum Beispiel, wenn ein Spanier, ein Uruguyaner, hm, sieht, wie Sie leben und ihr Leben ihm gefällt, kann er doch nicht Mennonite werden?
Julius Klüver: Nein. Es werden sehr große Ausnahmen ge..., es werden Ausnahmen gemacht. Wenn dieser, hm, Spanier oder andere Nationalitäten, wenn der in unserer Kolonie, in unserem Dorf wohnt und unsere Gebräuche und unsere Religion annimmt und unsere Sprache erlernt und unter unseren Leuten wohnt, dann kann eine Ausnahme gemacht werden. Dann muss er sich taufen lassen.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 132 - an interview with Mr. Julius Klüver - a so-called Leader of the Germanic Group of the Funkkasernen Camp in, hm, near München. This is the first case that we have interviewed a displaced person, who took—so to say - advantage of the situation in Russia to move west and to get to a country where their reluctance to carry arms because of religious principles should be respected. September 19, 1956 in Munich, Germany at the UNRA Detention Camp, a Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording. The machine is not at—in the best order, one condenser is broken, seems to be broken of, because the machine got a very rough ride. But nevertheless we took the record, because we hope that the transcription will be satisfactory. September 19, 1946—Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.